So far in this course, we've seen the operations of addition, subtraction,
multiplication, and division. We've also looked at some other symbols like
parentheses and brackets. There's actually another type of symbol we're going to
learn. It looks like this. Now, I'm not, not going to tell you what this means.
We're actually going to try and figure that out together. So, let's try and
figure this out through a story. I asked four people at Udacity how many candies
were in a jar. The person with the closest guess got to keep the whole jar.
Here's what they said. Katie said, 743. Kogure said, 728. Andy said, 714, and
Kathleen said, 746. There are 734 candies in the jar. Knowing this information,
who won the jar?